we've gone through all of this
complicated process of bringing our
representation of the 3d objects down
into two dimensions and then deciding
which pixels belong to which triangle or
which pixels are inside a triangle which
aren't which tells us which pixels we
need to light up on the screen but
there's a problem which is called the
visibility problem we want to render two
triangles to say triangle a and triangle
B a so using this whole system that
we've got before let's say let's say in
3d space that triangle a is in front of
triangle B so we go through our process
we transform the vertices interview
world spatial interview space we project
now and we decide which pixels are going
to be green and we render them into the
frame buffer and onto the screen at the
end then we do the same for B we go
through the whole process we collapse it
down to 2d we decide which pixels are
belonging to B and then we write them to
the screen but the problem is because B
was drawn after it overrides the pixels
that are already in the buffer on the
screen so this is a problem how do we go
about making sure that our
representation of the scene is
faithfully recorded when we convert from
the representation of triangles to
pixels how does we know which pixels are
in front of others the original and
simplest solution to this is just to
make sure that we draw our triangles in
the correct order which is called the
painterly algorithm because if you do it
like a painter would you draw the
background first so you render be first
and then you render a over the top of it
and that way the pixels that we end up
with represents the correct depth in the
scene we have the green pixels
overriding the ones that we drew of
mijin aliy the problem is that this
isn't very robust if these two
intersected or if you had
triangles that had more complex
overlapping A's inference of being but C
is in front of a but behind B somehow
then you can't necessarily order them
correctly more generally what the
problem is is that if you're ordering
them on say a per triangle or a per
object basis that's not quite enough to
say which pixel is in front of which
pixel because the operation needs to
happen at the pixel level so the
solution is to record the depth
information in another buffer so first
of all when we render a first remember a
is in front of B when we render a we
record at every pixel the depth
information for this triangle then when
we come to render B before we write the
color of B into the frame buffer what we
do is we do a test we say is the depth
at this pixel closer or further away
than the existing depth in the buffer if
it's closer to the eye then we can
safely overwrite because we know that B
isn't meant to be in front of a in that
case if it's further away we know that
in that specific case for that pixel B
is meant to be further away and we just
throw away results so let's say all of
these are at one unit out and then we
want to draw another triangle on top
what happens then is that the depth
values for the second triangle get sent
into this buffer and here we do a test
we say is the depth this pixel when
we're rendering this triangle is it
closer or further away than the depth
that's already in the buffer so let's
say these are all at depth nor point
five so that all be closer and in fact
then what we would do is override this
pixel that belongs to that triangle that
way we can do per pixel depth ordered
rendering without worrying about having
to order the geometry and about worrying
about not have to worry about special
cases and that's the solution that in
used to ubiquitously now in any kind of
3d rendering not necessarily just
because it's useful for solving this
problem because the depth buffer as
we'll find out actually has a lot of
other uses because when you finish
drawing your scene what you have is for
every pixel a depth value that tells you
exactly how far away it is from the eye
from the point of view of the viewer so
what you have is a coarse representation
of the scene which can be used for all
kinds of interesting purposes for
post-processing effects and for
generating shadows right yes that's a
complicated bro this is the area where
Zed buffering can be problematic because
if you want to draw a window or a tram
that transparent or translucent object
and you write its depth into the depth
buffer and then you draw another object
that's opaque
for example that needs to be behind the
transparent object it will fail the
depth test because it's behind the
transparent object so it's depth values
are further away than the windows so the
solution is simply to draw everything
opaque first and then afterwards you
turn off depth buffering or you don't
write to the depth buffer and you draw
your translucent or transparent
materials over the top and do blending
with what exists already in the frame
buffer because that way you won't have
problems whereby you look through a
window and everything that's behind it
isn't there it disappeared because it's
failing the depth test the problem of
course with that is that because you're
not using depth testing to draw
translucent or transparent objects you
start to run into the problem of well if
you're looking through window a at
window B you need to draw them in the
right order okay and I think for that
situation
the only real solution is just to fall
back to the painterly algorithm again
sort of all of the transparent objects
back to front draw B first and then a
and in general it works because the
majority of scenes composed mostly of
opaque objects that are amenable to Zed
testing and only occasionally will you
have a layer of transparency a window or
a cloud fog or something like that that
you need to look through and have that
rendered using the paint on the
algorithm very rarely will you have the
situations that break down where -
window was of different colors into
sects and things like that but there of
course there are ways of handling that
special case if you really really need
to do that kind of rendering but in most
circumstances the painterly algorithm
works fine for that
now what we've done is taken that simple
geometric representation and I've
discretized it we in general we prefer
to download in pieces because it lets
you adapt it means that you can decide
that things are great and give people a
high quality video or you can decide
that things are not going so well and
you could downgrade and try to make the
playback smoother